so here's the scene you're out at dinner
and your date orders the oysters I'll
take half a dozen of your finest sweet
water as they say and then they wink at
you like suggestively because of course
Easter's are supposed to be an
aphrodisiac but is it actually true joy
stirs make you horny true or false
a few years ago some Italian scientists
made the discovery they cracked open
some mollusks and found this particular
amino acid
it's called d-aspartic acid and that was
kind of a big deal because they knew
that in a different experiment
researchers had injected the aspartic
acid into some lab rats and the amino
acid appeared to raise both the
testosterone levels in the male rats and
the progesterone levels in the female
rats those higher hormone levels don't
necessarily guarantee the rats were
feeling especially sexual but the
connection could be made the catch of
course is that they didn't find it in
oysters they found it in mussels nobody
has managed to isolate a chemical in
oysters that could elevate hormone
levels in humans so when your date winks
over at you across that plate of fancy
oysters
they're probably more excited by the
idea
yeah then buy any special chemicals in
the bivalves themselves sadly this food
myth is false but hey go ahead and play
along with SIBO effect is a powerful
thing and there's no sense in wasting
those expensive bullets or ruining a
romantic night